ええええええ
20分
このランキングがあ
何度かのみなさんわかりますか
ヨギーとお隣の国中国や韓国が
ここに入っていません
ただ日本の動きが口の中になります
フェイスが困難2
実は
国月もあり重要な力を産金な
下着のブースの力を合わせです
鑑真なんですね
パワー企業が2019年に
hiro 瞑想を起こす力があるー
会社の調査せて男子に戻りますか
vip じゃないですか
日本の美容学校がいけないんですよ
4クラー
ウォークマンや
新幹線 year
八甲田れ歩道
そしてチキンラーメン注がれちゃう
こんな感じで我々は世の中を利用するような技術
そして社会派指摘
なのに今世界からは日本はイノベーティブ月にあってくるみたいじゃないんです
僕は幼い頃から周りもからたちから
日本の新座世界したんだよ
日本の技術は世界を見る沈んだよ
そんなことを言われていたので方かすごくショックを受けました
今日は皆さんに
僕の経験から
どうやったらはたリノベーション結果
世界にいると自分がわかる
そしてイノベーションのって言う
というアイデアを教えいたします
いきなりですけども
イノベーションと
いーでー
皆さん何思いますか
あの人は今早いの人コーチを思い浮かべるかもしれません
またある人は
人と強調するロボット思い浮かべるかもしれません
僕ら弊社課題名声
5個イノベーションと自由に自分たちのアイディアを出し合って
そして議論がされて言って何かを生み出していく
そんなものをイメージしまう
僕は学生の頃から
イノベーションを期したいそんなことを思い
it 魚鱗倒したりー
rb 村家博かそのされるイベントに参加して自分自身のアイディアを形にする
そんな活動ちょっと来られてみました
預言者の対戦で5話
大学を卒業する時もをされる
僕は-1イノベーションとれい名前を作る
むしろみました
ちょっとプレイ所入ります
そうそうして僕は社会人になってからもう夜なべが新しいものを生み出し
ずっと2レイプが
毎日毎日僕は会社のために一生懸命働きましたーーー
ただ気づくと
僕は市はリカー
会社にしがみつくこと野路町店米で
会社の目標や
増資が投資に言われたことをキャラただ同じようになりました
ん
その後からは僕は仕事方の少なくです
仕事がつまらなくている
5のリカー同僚や先輩奴に
家をこぼしようになっていました
そしていつしかうわぁ
このままじゃイノベーションを起こせない
そんな風に思うようになります
だってそのと思う
僕らみたいに金なかったから
会員深いはまったくもって中ら最後になっている
のアイディア集にし休みだったことはまったくできませんでした
スポーツが求めるよく今ここにあるだろう
そんなことを常に考えるようになりました
そしてある時僕は
シリコン前に呼ばれたデザインす賃金ループ
言われる
授業を受ける機会がございましたーーー
そこにまさに僕が求めていたのもあったんです
まさにこの場では
自分のアイディアを自由にシェアして
そして自由に議論して
そして何かを新しいものを目指していた
そんな関節が正常されていたのです
この時に向かう思いましたん
僕が行かなきゃ行けない場所知り狛枝がしるこば値引きは僕の求めているノベーション
があるん
恋から僕はシリコンバレーに入ることを決めました
ただ恥ずかしながら当時の僕は待った警報ができず大学院を卒業していましたが
国際学会のでなくともなくる
英語で論文を書いたことすらありませんでしたーー
だけど僕はシリコンバレーが持つはれていますが僕の日々だした場所だ
総合一生懸命勉強しました
毎日毎日時間を内田で強振
そして今日も一生懸命で影響
この努力の甲斐神の部下もありませんが僕はシリコンバレーのとあるぴをやりたいこと
になりました
シリコンバレーで聞いて皆さんどんなイメージを持ちますか
シリコンバレーはアメリカ西海岸カリフォルニア州のサンフランシスコから
さんがてるまでの一帯を一般的にを指します
thanks 公というと桜
このはずが有名ですよね
人たぶん産果実とは観光地としてすごくいい言えばそれ
ん
ただそれだけじゃないんです
実はた後
google や
アップや
amazon や
facebook といった
世界をリードするような
it を引いたここ2本竿決まっ
さらにわー
イノベーションのか来たら技術を持っている
新しいいいと入手
d 米大学もここには存在します
uc バークレーや
スター込んでいた世界克服持続レベルの言及したつ
それも同じ文字しています
そうこんな夢のような場所に
僕はきたわけです
そして僕が当たることになった会社は僕の想像を遥かに超えるものでした
こんな感じでー無料のランチが提供されたり
無料の通りのもや無料のスナックに行ってくださるんです
このに置いて考えるでしょ
それだけでなく言う
仕事に鍛えたら自分でトレーニングをしてリフレッシュしてそして仕事に戻る
ソファに小皿変猫流れたら仕事や
下ドライバーの卓球をしてそして動画たちとコミュニケーションを取っている
コミュニケーションを活性化していた3
聞いてん4日したい文字た知られました
そしていってことが効率的にできるのであればというところで
旅行先から仕事をするになるということを許されていました
そしてキャロ仕込んでルー
line 混んである木目が打つことができるのです
治安僕は全く水とできませんでした
そう
シリコンバレーはまさに今回のメロウな職場環境を押すだけ
ただ僕は金メダルは
この職場環境だしではありません
とある日仕事はに僕はゆずいた人あるバールって
アメリカでどうやって創業入らせるか
その議論を新緑なくいただけることです
人の勝手につきましたーーー
そういえばアメリカに来て
まったく仕事の不二家増資の悪口を言ってないんだと
そこで部下は思い切って聞いてみました
毎朝全く仕事の愚痴とか上司の話はないようなん
そうすると気がポカーンとした顔持続を見ましたら
そして
あるようになりました
いやああああ
いやだったら良い歯医者
僕は凍りつきました
そしてございました ei エリア
仕事ってもそんなに簡単にあげないでしょ
そうすると
友人やってまいりました
mother
それは君の努力草けどルームだけでしょ
世界はシンプルなんだよ
好きなことだったら続ければいい
嫌なことだったらやめればいい
好きなことを続けいえばそれが自分自身の専門性になくて
そしてそれで仕事ができるんだよと
僕は何もありませんでした
だって日本だったら我慢しなさい
我慢していたらきっと5回もだろうそんなふうにはあるんじゃないですか
だけど保ち生い立ちはそんな考え方してないんです
自分のために生きてるんです
自分が好きなことであれば続ける
やることでたらダメるー
そんな風に生きているんです
だからでしょ僕の周りにはそんな人たちが普通みました
2ヶ月から仕事を休んでいきなり頭をかけるために日本自由
半年間好きなプロジェクトに携わってそして仕事を変える
仕事を辞めて1年間海外旅行に行って自分探しをする
こんな人は立ついましたし
こんな人が別に特別だというふうにバーンたの指導を割りませんでした
そうだか内装
こんな風にして自分自身が本当に好きな事を歌いで
自分の立っ
だから会議のあり方や会議の雪ばは大きく異なっていましたーーー
みんな自分のカラーを出して
自分の戦後長いたして
自分の意見を付けて会議を出していくんです
だから僕はいつも回目終わった後に僕が多い気もしなかったような
あ家をいっぱいもらっていましたーーー
スポクラなことは整備
会議のあとは僕は思いつきもしなかったようなアイデアだ増えていました
僕はこうしてイノベーションの本質は自分自身が多分
て1
ずんの本当に好きなことがあって
そしてその人たちはアイドル誓うことによって起きるだ
そんなことに続いて日本を投稿しました
皆さんもご存知かもしれませんが今日本は非常に厳しい状況です
高齢化によってい
日本の経済を支えることは非常に難しくなっております
そして今レースですように
日本の西洋将来の経済の成長はすごく当たるものではありません
だからの巷ではイノベーションの必要性が叫ばれておか
だけどどうでしょうか
イノベーションの本質はあなた自身が仕事を楽しむことを
あなた自身が
のために生きることなんです
ですが通れ会社ももらった
リサーチのこと日本人の仕事が満足らは世界にふぁい p です
世界に一番仕事を楽しんでいないです
僕はにもに帰ってから
自分の本当に好きな事をやろうそんな風に言うことを決めました
だから黒子好きだったよべーション
候補32
世界で農具世界のベーション起こそうとしていくと新しい宿に新しい技術を作ろうとし
てみた家
そんな人をつけて一緒にイノベーションを起こすようなだけ対応して
仕事を始めました
それだけではありません
僕は僕自身どうイノベーションを起こす作業で
スタートアップいる仕事も始めました
ただ僕が件これだけでないとダメなんです
新たらぁぁ
自分に広い方は来て認識に来てる人があるです
あなたが自分の豊か3月3日
そうすることによってい
きっと新たな専門性が固まってきます
そして
あなたの髪価値は高まってきたのにあなたあなたはごっそり会社で出てきます
してそんな人たちが集まって意見を使えば一回の会社をこれが起きるはずなんですね
高田というというでしょう
そんなあなたになると知るダルい
よれば束4だったねーよ
我慢しなさいと思う
だけど世界一で皆そう
こんな考えませんだろうからだけなんです
世界に出ると自分の好きなことをただただ地球しがち
ファイル
きっと世界で言うと新た自身の価値観
4妻あなたが本当にはなかったことに気が
あなたの主観だというかあります
崩壊したーー
そんなあなたたちと
自分用を磨いてあなたたちと日本に日本でイノベーション補正とついています
ありがとうございます
はぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]